hey everyone welcome and thank you for
coming to my talk my name is Matt Baker
at a company called rally software owned
boulder colorado
my responsibilities there include
development and maintenance of our
containerized build system so we're
doing a lot of things with docker in
particular over the past my background
is in infrastructure automations and
operations and over the past 10 years
I've been in charge of managing from
hundreds to thousands of servers and
it's really been my my passion at rally
they afford us a large amount of time
for hacking on projects that we find to
be interesting and or you know really
anything that we that we want to do and
so over the past year I've spent most of
my hack time as well as a lot of
personal free time looking into
technology that I believe is the next
step in virtualization after containers
and that's what we're here to talk about
today so complexity in our systems are
it comes in two varieties right we have
necessary complexity which are complex
complexity that's due to solving
problems that are very hard and and and
very complex within themselves now we
also have complexity that is sort of
unnecessary this is driven from a lack
of understanding of the problem or
perhaps organic growth over time so
let's take a look at today's modern
containerized architecture so we start
up here and we have you know our edge
facing services we have some dynamic DNS
and traffic routing and that gets its
configuration information from our
service metadata our service registries
such as at CD or zookeeper we have
various types of stores we have memory
stores such as Redis and memcache D we
have object storage such as Swift and s3
as well as relational database stores
such as post grass and Maria DB and also
document D B's such as CouchDB and
go now we also this is our primary
applications running polyglot
applications running on the platform
itself and these are all tied together
with orchestration such as kubernetes
and Mayo's and we we control all this
and manage all of this with
configuration management such as puppet
and ansible and chef these systems work
for us but they're extremely complex
they're very hard for reason about as a
whole and debugging is difficult one of
the reasons that makes debugging
difficult is it's almost impossible to
replicate the environment in which
you're running one-to-one and there are
many many layers of supporting code here
if we dig in to our application stack
itself and this is just what would be
you know running our application
directly you can see we start down at
the hardware and have Hardware drivers
and a hypervisor that uses them to
segregate our hardware and then split it
up and then on top of that we have our
operating system like a bun 2 or Sint OS
or any other Linux based service now
that uses virtual hardware drivers and
the kernel and and user process keep
everything isolated and running and then
on top of that we add on our docker run
time now within the docker container we
have the shared libraries that our
application needs we have the language
runtime we have the application itself
and the application config now there are
many layers of abstraction and isolation
in this it's hard to know how
everything's going to interact all the
time many up there are many upgraded
upgrade Cadence's to match when you need
a new functionality new functionality up
here and your language runtime there's a
lot of upgrade Cadence's to match and a
large portion of this was redundant
we have isolation here at the hypervisor
layer we have isolation here with user
processes and then we have isolation
again within docker and this is all to
run a single app with a single user on a
single server and this leads to some
problems such as unnecessary complexity
problems now from a development
perspective from a developer's
perspective there are a lot of black box
layers underneath the app
that's actually running and and the
developers normally are not interacting
with these layers explicitly and so it
can seem very much so like a black box
there they're used implicitly but you
know they're not necessarily knowing
exactly how it's interacting and as far
as they're concerned it may as well be
Turtles all the way down there we also
have over generalized systems POSIX is
by its nature generalized it was
invented in a time or created in a time
in which we were running the same
application against a constantly set
constantly changing set of hardware well
now that's not necessarily needed as
much we're more or less running our
virtual machines on hypervisors and we
have a handful of virtual device drivers
and that's about it the systems in the
Micra service architecture are by
designed very specific and so the over
generalization can become a little bit
of a problem a huge amount of complexity
is within the Linux kernel with
protection you know the kernel is one of
the main jobs of the kernel is to keep
the kernel safe from applications and
users to keep users safe from
applications safe from users
applications safe from each other and
users is safe from each other as well
that's a that's a lot of code and a lot
of complex complexity in this system and
there's also a lot of needless
permission checks operating system
permissions are not only hard but it's
an outdated model from the time sharing
computers of the 50s and 60s in which
you had many applications and many users
on the same piece of hardware all
interacting and all having to work with
each other and to end to get this get a
job done while on the same system it's
very hard to get right and it's
time-consuming to reason about and
develop now we also have some efficiency
and duplication problems as well we're
using a lot of storage and RAM for
things that may not be in use we have
various drivers on the system when
reality we're only interfacing with disk
and network virtual drivers but we still
have floppy disk drivers kicking around
and you know tape drive drivers and all
these other things we have a lot of our
not a lot but there may be unconsidered
or unstarted services on on your system
as well there are services on your
system that are running and not
necessarily being utilized and just
taking up resources and there are also
duplicated services that are running in
maybe too many places such as SSH if you
have a bashing host that connected that
allows you to connect into your repple
running SSH on all your hosts as well is
not necessary now patching and and
upgrading software is a consuming and
risk time consuming and risky business
keeping track of all the patches then
Nerada that need to be applied is a very
daunting task and applying Afra patches
after hours is not super fun as any of
you know patching in addition patching
is not at this point I'm broken down
normally into functionality versus
security when we go in and patch a
system we're going yum update and
applying everything that is there
whether it's security or functionality
and if it's not in use why are we paying
the price for it and if you look at it
in the right light it looks like maybe
our micro service architecture sort of
duplicates what Linux is doing for us we
have our configuration here you know the
service registration and sed key value
stores we have our process management
going on here with kubernetes and mesos
we have our in memory storage in our
disk storage and then we have our
individual worker processes themselves
this it this sorry this it sort of
duplicates what the Linux system has
done for us and it it almost is
identical to what we're relying on Linux
for at this point in time now there are
also a few security problems and this is
just a very short list I'm sure if you
ask your local security engineer he'll
be able to elaborate on this much much
more in depth
than animal we have a very large attack
surface the kernel itself is a huge code
base there's a with a larger code base
there's a it's easier to find entry
points into the system and to get in and
compromise the application in addition
there's a lot of common applications
services configurations and libraries
that are on our Linux deployments and
the security patching is done by a
separate team this is normally done at
the operating system level there are a
lot of unknown interactions because each
change that we're applying is a
different size and different shape and
it's going to affect our systems in
different ways and every every time we
do that update we don't know exactly how
it's going to affect us this can lead to
possible production outages which which
we can't handle we are rather we don't
want to experience and it's also
problematic because the people who are
applying it don't have a full
understanding there's a lack of
understanding of the implementation of
the code that they're actually upgrading
now most of the codes out most of the
exploits out there these days do target
Linux a larger user base equals a larger
chance of successful attacks and attacks
against the hypervisor are slightly less
common the hypervisor is more secured
it's not necessarily exposed on the
internet and so you see a lot fewer
attacks in order to develop an attack
against a hypervisor normally you need
to have a machine on the box either via
managed hosting or AWS or something like
that and in these cases we've taken
precautions in order to negate that and
sort of limit the capabilities of these
of these servers and since everything is
so common and attacked on one deployment
of Linux can be you know in theory be
applied to other deployments that are
out there as well and with a darker
based platform there's a lot of sharing
going on we're sharing the kernel we're
sharing memory we're sharing filesystem
as well as the hardware and really the
only thing that's keeping us safe or
some kernel extensions such as C groups
and stuff like that we're sort of
building a wall of protection now how
did we get here well we got here over
natural
evolution we've evolved to use different
architectures and hardware we've gone
from mainframes to client-server
architectures to distributed micro
services and UNIX has supported us the
entire way we have decorative decades of
backwards compatibility built into Linux
that it there's no real easy way to
remove it you can't go in and carve out
the things that you don't want in an
easy way and I would even wager that at
this point in time you could install the
latest Ubuntu distribution on a
ten-year-old Pentium One and everything
would work as expected
what can Linux run on anything
what can run on Linux anything it's them
one of the most compatible operating
systems out there even though we're only
running a single app with a single user
on virtual hardware this has developed a
culture of compatibility over efficiency
and this is one of the trade-offs that
we that we've made now it allows us to
do everything we need to do very easily
this we are able to do what we need to
do and part of that reasons why we're
able to do that is the great tooling
ecosystem with things like ansible and
AWS and OpenShift and OpenStack we're
able to build these really cool complex
systems and and this has gotten us to
where we are today and and we're in a
working State we are able to build and
deploy of working micro service
architectures that solve our problems in
a fairly elegant way we've made it work
and now it's time to make it right and
the next time next iteration we'll be
focusing on performance and making it
fast
and the way we can do that is by
simplifying fewer lines of code equals
fewer bugs and fewer things to reason
about and it gives us a better ability
to hold the system within our mind and
and to think about and solve problems
and that's why I propose that we start
thinking about using unicorns now what
is a unit Colonel a unit colonel is a
specialized virtual machine that
contains your application your
applications compiled in with its
configuration the language runtime
and a set of libraries that interact
with the virtual hardware known as a
library operating system and we take a
look here we can see this this part we
have our application binary config
dependencies and these are sort of
packaged up with your languages tools
the normal build tools that you're using
now and then we sort of bundle it with
the language runtime and some virtual
hardware drivers via a unicorn ol
packaging tool now these tools vary by
distribution with Erlang sling it's the
railing tool with a mirage OS it's the
Mirage tool and for runtime genius its
runtime of file but these are
implementation specific tools that do
this packaging for us now what it looks
like is similar to our application stack
well rather it's serving the same
functionality we're still running our
app we still have our hardware Hardware
drivers and hypervisor down at the base
level in our application binary up on
top but we've replaced the middle with a
library OS now this is only the code
that is absolutely required it's your
language runtime your application and
virtual IO drivers and this can also be
minimized down to a very basic POSIX
interface as well then we take these
Munich kernels that have these artifacts
have everything they need to interact
with the hypervisor in the world around
them and so they can be deployed
directly against the lowest
virtualization lever which level which
is the the hypervisor they have their
own network stack they have their own
virtual virtualized memory presented as
hardware and they're totally
self-contained and ideally immutable as
well normally if you're going to be
persisting state somewhere you're going
to persist it off of these now comparing
them directly to a docker stack you can
see there's a lot less complexity going
on here there are much fewer layers as
you can see and even though this model
accomplishes the same thing they're
significantly less code there's no
permissions
there's no isolation and there's no
unused libraries now within unit kernels
there are two types there are POSIX
compliant types
and these are targeted towards
backwards-compatibility and running your
unmodified application in a minimal
footprint they're fairly generalized and
more backwards compatible but they do
allow you to run your unmodified
application in a kernel type fashion
we're taking advantage of some of the
things such as efficiency that you can
get front and end size at least now you
don't necessarily get all the benefits
of decreased complexity but you do get
you are able to run in a unit kernel
type architecture or without modifying
your application now looking forward we
have forward forward compatible ones
which are more language specific type
and so these are lean mean and
specialized and these really take
advantage of all the things that you
know kernels can offer now there's very
little backwards compatibility in there
though so how can you know kernels help
address our problems well taking a look
at our unnecessary complexity problems
we've removed a significant layer a lot
of layers of complexity we've removed
backwards support backwards
compatibility and legacy support and we
really only include what we need and so
this makes the symp the the system that
we're designing significantly more
simple we've also shrunken and
specialized our runtimes fewer lines of
code equals fewer bugs a smaller
codebase is easier to reason about and
you know our mean time to resolution on
these priority one bugs can go down
significantly also because everything is
so small and and so compact we can
really increase our density and reach
much higher densities on our commodity
hardware that we're running right now
now with no other users that in a
time-sharing sense the application can
really utilize the system in any way it
wants there's a single process and
single memory space so there's no need
for permissions there's much less
complexity in the in the corresponding
library OS to support this and this
doesn't mean that your
application itself can't support
multiple users this just means that
there's no no users no multiple users in
the sense of Etsy password which is not
really relevant since 2010 we're we're
not necessarily or ideally we're not
logging into these machines at all we're
running our application in our
application only in an immutable way now
we have isolation at the virtual
hardware layer this is the the lowest
level that we can isolate other than
physical machines but we don't want to
own a fleet of infinite physical
machines isolation at this level is the
simplest and most effective it's the
smallest footprint and smallest area to
secure now taking a look at our
efficiency problems a minimal VM even
with nothing on it say you want to just
have a VM you're still looking at about
a gigabyte in size a minimal unit kernel
is is tiny its kilobytes in size and so
even with a full unit kernel you're
you're still looking at megabytes and in
size and so that means you can go ahead
and say we were going to deploy a static
side if we were to deploy a static site
on nginx on Linux we're going to take up
a about a gig ram and about a gig at
disk well if we were to do that in you
know kernels we could run a static site
with you know about 4 megabytes of RAM
and they you know even less disk now our
micro service architecture sort of
duplicates Linux since we have built and
maintained these architectures which are
very time consuming and they take a lot
of effort to build in a lot of effort in
time and and thought to build and
maintain we should use it as much as we
can we should use it to replace the
things that that it can replace and do
that as effectively as possible now
there's no permission checks at all and
so you can really eke out every bit of
performance out of your hardware you can
run your application and direct kernel
CPU mode and so without any permissions
checks anywhere anywhere and you're able
to utilize your Hardware a hundred
percent and this also raises a curious
it removes that layer of abstraction in
which you're required most Linux systems
or rather Linux was developed with the
abstraction being in the file well
without that abstraction being there we
can go ahead and think about things in
new ways and one thing that that I read
the other days that someone as opposed
instead of taking things off of the
network writing it to disk as a file and
then reading it back out they were
proposing taking network packets off the
off of the network writing that's
stripping off the headers and writing
those to disk and then when you go to
read it you're reading network packets
directly off of the disk so it gives us
a different way of thinking about things
if we so choose now is when it comes to
security problems we have a very small
attack service now it's really only our
application and the libraries that are
required there's no extraneous software
on there and there's very few shared
libraries interacting and almost every
deployment is completely different so
even if you're able to get into one
deployment that attack is not going to
work on the employer on another
deployment down down the internet
there's no real common entry point
either each deployment is very unique
and the other thing is that once you
know kernel is compromised there's
really very little you can do since
there's no software other than what
you're what is required to run your
application there's no shell there's no
compiler you don't have any access to
the memory around you you have only
what's in your applications memory so
we're no longer in the realm of script
kiddies sort of scanning IPs finding a
compromise WordPress and installing an
editor egg drop bot now you're looking
at professional hackers getting in and
even once they get in they really only
have access to the memory of the service
memory and code of the service that they
have compromised now this may not hold
true forever as unit kernels grow in
popularity there may be attacks that
target the library os's and whatnot but
it is still much more specialized and
more unique than a standard Linux
install and we can also have dev teams
manage manage their own patching the
team that wrote it runs it the team that
implemented the the software is fully
able to reason about the impact of an
upgrade to a library or some other piece
of software within their system and the
ownership of the entire runtime it is
within their hands and so when they're
developing and hit a bug or a problem
that is unfamiliar to them there's no
chance that it's related to the
production runtime environment or
something outside of their codebase it's
it's only using the code that they have
explicitly included and so when they
reach a problem like that they can know
that the code the problem is with the
code that they're writing and
essentially the only thing that is
shared is the hardware ideally you're
running a a type 1 hypervisor and the
only real commonality is the hardware
between unit kernels now there is a
shared kernel in the sense that Xen
itself is a kernel but the applications
are not interacting with it in the same
way that they would be with a standard
Linux kernel there it's providing the
segregation of hardware for them but
nothing else now this doesn't always
hold true as we don't always run type 1
hypervisor x' but still even if you're
running a type 2 hypervisor such as k vm
or Xen on top of a bun - and sorry let
me back up up we split up hypervisors in
two ways
type 1 is a hypervisor that runs on the
hardware itself there's no operating
system other than the hypervisor itself
type 2 would be something like k vm who
runs within the linux user space and and
provides virtualization in that way so
in if you're running it as type 2 you do
still have a Linux system underneath but
it is as low down as low as you're going
to get in the stack without running a
type 1 hypervisor now there are a few
people there are quite a few projects
out there in the wild and we're
go over a couple of them here but if you
don't see one that looks super
interesting to you Google unit colonel
in the language of your choice and I
expect you'll be able to find something
that you find interesting and useful and
are able to play with the first one
we're going to talk about here is Mirage
OS Mirage OS is a language specific unit
kernel that utilizes the Oh camel
language it's developed by the
University of Cambridge and is released
under the MIT license it supports both
Xen and UNIX as a runtime and the reason
why they support UNIX is so that you're
able to go ahead and develop and iterate
within UNIX running your unit kernel in
Linux user space and then once you're
ready go ahead and package that up and
seal it and ship it out as a production
ready Yoona kernel so it gives you fast
development iterations while still being
able to utilize Yoona kernels so you're
not building this thing every five
minutes it supports both x86
architectures and rant arm and so that's
very interesting you're able to run
these on any type of ARM based device as
well as standard x86 hardware which is
very cool the next one is rubbed run
rump run is a POSIX compliant unit
kernel it's written in C and developed
by the net BSD community it's licensed
under BSD but as these things go if you
include various libraries they may have
different licenses as well
it supports x86 and arm as well and this
is the first implementation of net BSD
is any kernel concept the net BSD any
kernel is a version of the BSD kernel
that they've modified to make modular
and so you're able to take pieces from
here and pieces from there and put them
together and use what you need from that
kernel while not including the whole
thing and this has gone through a lot of
work in order for them to make it like
that the next one we're going to talk
about is runtime j/s this is a language
specific unit kernel that's based on the
JavaScript v8
and this is developed primarily by the
open-source community and it's licensed
under Apache v2 the supported runtimes
are KTM and the architecture is pretty
much x86 now if you're just beginning to
play with these this is a very good
place to start you're able to use NPM
and node and the tools that a lot of us
are familiar with in order to begin
developing and running sites within
yoona kernels without having to pick up
Haskell or Erlang or okay Amal although
with this crowd I expect we all like
those a little bit better
another one is link this is also known
as Erlang on Zen and they also have
another project called project L which
is a type typesafe version of the beam
implementation so this uses Erlang it's
developed by cloud Dozier LLP it's it's
under a commercial license a sleepycat
type license and it runs on Zen or it
runs on Zen and it supports the x86
architecture the next one is the hal vm
that's the haskell lightweight vm this
is promoted as a simple platform for
simple platforms it's language specific
and the language it targets is Haskell
it's developed by Galois and there are a
few guys here today from them and
they're very cool group of people and
they'd happily be able to talk to you a
little bit more in depth about this but
it's licensed under the bsd 3 clause it
supports Xen as well as x86 and it's a
very cool project this is what the
workshop yesterday was based off of now
here's one that you might not expect
this is Microsoft drawbridge this is a
research project by Microsoft that
combines lightweight Pico processes with
a Microsoft or Windows library OS in
order to accomplish a same unit kernel
type goal unfortunately this is just an
internal research project and I've had a
very hard time finding any code
available for this online and
to play with it or to try it at all but
it is very interesting that Microsoft is
looking at this one of the most popular
ones out there at this point in time is
OS V this is a POSIX compliant unit
kernel it sits in C and it's developed
by claudius systems it's under the bsd
license but they also offer commercial
support and some are commercial license
they have some implementations that are
commercially licensed now what's really
interesting is that this will support
running an unmodified JVM as well as a
lot of other unmodified applications and
the other very interesting thing is they
don't target just KTM and Xen they also
target VMware and VirtualBox meaning
that you can run these on a
windows-based VMware cluster they focus
on performance and they actually have
just released a product which is a
database based on unit earnings which is
a Cassandra type or Cassandra compatible
data store called skill Adibi which
seems to be very interesting another one
that we have here is Clive Clive is a
language specific library OS that
targets the golang language it's
developed at the Universidad Ray Ray
Juan Carlos of Madrid and Spain and it's
under the MIT license they target
primarily hardware and they run on x86
architectures there's not a ton of
information out there but it does seem
to be a very promising product that
would allow you to run your your go
based application as a unit hurdle and
the final one we're going to talk about
here is any C's click OS this is a
language specific you know kernel that's
built for primarily networking
applications it's in C++ and developed
by NEC labs now it's under an MIT
license but it does have a clause that
requires you to get written permission
before using any C's name publicly it
supports Xen and KVM and the x86
architecture and as I mentioned this
really targets
specifically networking hardware and and
networking gear such as software-defined
networking and other embedded network
type systems and so that's what I have
here for the presentation now in lieu of
doing a live demo which everyone does
find interesting and ahhing
i've created a demo that you guys can
all do yourself and so at this address
here at this github repo you'll find a
vagrant repository or rather a github
repository that has a vagrant box as
well as a few directories in it now that
if you do a vagrant up this this machine
will work on either Windows or Linux or
Mac either VMware or VirtualBox and it
will allow you to go ahead and try and
build and run these you know kernels and
so the first example in there is a
mirage OS example it'll will allow you
to build a static website with Mirage
and go ahead and deploy it against the
Xen hypervisor and see what you what is
deployed in addition it includes Jitsu
Jitsu is just in time you know kernel
summoning and so the way it works is
that you'll go ahead and fire up this
jitsu daemon which responds listens on
port 53 UDP and acts as a DNS server or
and a forwarding proxy as well and the
way it works is when a DNS request comes
in jitsu will check the hypervisor see
if the you know kernel that is there to
serve the request as running is running
if it is it will go ahead and restart
and return your a record if it is not
jitsu will go ahead and deploy that unit
kernel then return your response and you
have your able to access the page so
while there's no traffic on it there's
no nothing running whatsoever other than
the DNS daemon now this isn't super
practical but it is very cool and it is
something that you may find interesting
to play with the other project another
one that's in there is a Lane based
buena kernel which is written in Erlang
it's a generic or very very basic Erlang
OTP application that serves a static
website and you can go ahead and compile
that down with rebar which was included
package it with railing and run that
against the Zen
our visor as well there's also an
example of runtime je s and the Moriah
their rump kernel as well the rubber n'
now the rump one is a little bit more
complex and it might be something that's
a little bit more useful for you to play
with it's actually a full wordpress
stack it includes
one muna colonel serving my sequel one
unit colonel running PHP in fast cgi
mode and then a front unit colonel
running nginx and it's a full stack
you're able to go ahead build these you
know kernels spin them up and install
WordPress on them and so I really
encourage you all to go ahead and clone
this repo do a vagrant up and start
playing with this and build some cool
stuff these unicorns are being used in
production and there are production
things out there so they are ready to
start playing with and I assure you you
will not be wasting your time or your
interest looking into this stuff and
that's all I have for you today and I
appreciate you all for coming out thank
you